hi I'm Mona tamata I play Claudia key
sheep
hi I'm Shay read off that phrase we go
hi I'm Sophie grace and I play Christi
Thomas hi my name is Mona Baker I play
Mary Ann spear hi I'm Sachi Gomes and I
played on Schaefer I am mark Feuerstein
and I play the role of Watson brewer I'm
Elysia Silverstone and I've already
forgotten my name I think it's Elizabeth
this is Thomas thank you and we're
taking a BuzzFeed quiz to find out which
baby-sitters club character we are which
position would you hold in your own
baby-sitters club president vice
president secretary treasurer marketing
officer or alternate officer I would
definitely be the president I agree you
guys think I would I mean you're pretty
good with social medias yeah I totally
agree I cannot decide your team
president you're really smart with the
social media like you said I mean you
could totally be a president or a vice
president I feel like a vice president
is fun yeah I can see you as I and I'm
gonna go right for the top of the
masthead president I'm not choosing it
because I know that I'm qualified to be
the president I'm just using it because
I wanna be president of the baby-sitters
club well my young self for sure would
have been fix president my adult self
would probably pick alternatives so I
don't have to do cuz I'm too overwhelmed
but when I was a kid for sure president
oh is a treasurer at my elementary
school I went out for treasurer and I
got treasurer so I'm gonna say a
secretary with baby-sitters club at my
school I used to help the second turns
up it was really fun
I gotta say choose something to add to
your kid kit a fun movie friendship
bracelets board games a book of
mysteries Legos or slime I am a movie
junkie I have to admit but I think we
could watch a fun movie and then we
could pick our favorite characters and
maybe act out different scenes if we
wanted I probably save friendship
bracelet just because you can do a lot
of things as well during French place
let's
you know it takes a bit of time so you'd
be able to watch a movie you'd be able
to talk do you also just that I would
definitely choose friendship bracelets
because like my first instinct was movie
but like you're not really interacting
with your babes I mean I think I would
do board games because I loved playing
board games with my babysitter's all the
time I would totally do board games as
well
mama I see you as a Candyland kind of
girl yes I was just gonna say I play
Candyland all the time I'm gonna go with
board games my family we love board
games I think it sounds really soothing
and healing is sort of meditative to do
the friendship bracelets but in reality
I think board games would be super fun
so I'm gonna go for dips to choose a
young celeb you trust to join the VSC
I got to Timothy shower many Lana Condor
Jojo C WA camera McLaughlin Sofia Willis
and a Mangla Stenberg let's be honest I
I got the pleasure of working with
Timothy Salome on Royal Pains he did an
episode and he was brilliant even then
but there's no way I'm choosing him to
be in the BSC I mean who's leaving their
child but Timothy Allen I'm gonna go
with a Mangla Steinberg badly you've
never seen I need these cute people's
faces before because I clearly live
under a rock but I'm gonna go with Colm
because he looks super cute I only
choose when to condor because I feel
like she's a very trustworthy person
yeah I feel like I'm a I think I'm gonna
pick Landon Condor - these are all
really really good candidates
Wow I think man I'm just thinking Sofia
Willis yeah she's awesome
yeah I'm gonna go Sofia I think I'm
gonna go with you - what are you doing
after school on non BSC meeting dates
Model UN debate dance committee
you have club Peter for creative writing
I'm totally going creative writing I
love it I have to go with dance
committee
I play creative writing because in
elementary school and my second grade
teacher made us have these like journals
where we would write our own stories
every single week
and it was literally the highlight of my
week I made to be on the purple hippo so
I'm a creative guy for sure I think I'd
have to say debate I honestly do like
proving people wrong it's a fun little
hobby of mine and I know it sounds
really cruel and evil
I'd say theater just because I've done a
lot of theater news have done a lot of
theater um so how much is that one
my young self would probably have picked
dance for me as a my young self would
have picked Model UN because I would
have thought that looked good on a
resume my older self is picking Model UN
because my son he actually proposed a
Model UN in his school here in LA and
they hit one I would pick Model UN did
you pick one
I'm so stressed out right now well I
know BuzzFeed could could listen to us
for days sorry I'm so sorry Model UN
they're done pick a side character from
the baby-sitters club me me
Karen brewer Logan Bruno Blaine Jeanine
Keisha or Esme Porter's last move in of
destiny I'd say more than once me I
think I'm gonna pick Karen Brewer I know
Mimi she was so cute and sweet and
supportive of Claudia I'm picking Karen
Berger cuz she's crazy and I'm not the
real girl but you know the character
she's late that's my further because I'm
really into crystals and spirituality
and manifestation so I definitely
resonate with her I'm gonna go with
Karen Brewer because I think she is like
the funniest character and just like
acting what there was so much fun I
think
not just because Claudia loves Mimi I'll
go with Mimi because I love spending
time with my grandma finally pick an
iconic 90's team to join your squad
lisa's turtle from Saved by the Bell
cher Horowitz from clueless gia Campbell
from Sister Sister Sabrina from Sabrina
the Teenage Witch Ashley banks from The
Fresh Prince of bel-air
or Lindsay Weir from Freaks and Geeks
this is obvious I mean how do you not go
with cher Horowitz from clueless come on
I'm picking it too cuz the only other
one I know is say from the Bell I don't
I know for me I'm gonna pick a sh Li
brings from The Fresh Prince of bel-air
there's no doubt in my mind I'm gonna
say Lindsay key from six weeks the two
most iconic to me are Cher and Sabrina
but I think Sabrina I am totally torn
between cher Ashlee and Sabrina because
I love Cher and elysia plays my mom I
watched Sabrina the Teenage Witch like
over and over again with my sister in
fourth and fifth grade but Fresh Prince
of bel-air is just so iconic I don't
know I think I'm gonna go with Ashley
banks I think I'm gonna have to go with
Cher
I got Christi Thomas note soccer there
you're a natural-born leader headstrong
and can take charge of any situation
that is so nice Claudia Keyshia's
everyone comes to you for fashion advice
you are hands-down the most stylish
middle schooler in Stoneybrook
that definitely sounds like me oh my I
got Stacey McGill at first you might
come off a little intimidate but what
does people get to know you
they're glad to be in your orbit house
sounds just like I got there dawn
Schafer you stand up for the little guy
and can't stand when injustice occurs I
got Stacey McGill you're sophisticated
mature and classiest heck I don't think
I'm a style of concern so I can serve my
go-to item I'm Kristy Thomas my daughter
oh my god is so lucky you the president
I'm dawn Schafer
I love dawn you're extremely earnest
kind and you wear your heart on your
sleeve
that's beautiful mark the way
[Music]